[Music]
outriders is a drop-in dropout co-op
rpg shooter coming from square enix and
action gaming veterans people can fly
don't need to see you get eaten on day
one as one of the eponymous outriders
you are a human gifted with mysterious
supernatural abilities
trying to survive on enoch an incredibly
hostile planet that really doesn't want
you there
stick together if we want to survive if
you're familiar with people can fly's
previous work
outriders continues to play to their
strengths namely fast
violent relentless and extremely gory
action
that said there's a newfound focus on
rpg elements too such as character
classes experience points
and skill trees as well as a rich story
and deep lore
oh and loot let's not forget sweet sweet
loot
as is now standard armor and weaponry
falls into a range of categories
from standard to legendary with the
quality and efficacy of perks and set
bonuses escalating to match
outriders legendary weapons really earn
their reputation too
let's take a look at some of these
deranged and deadly creations
give your enemies the mother of all
headaches with the meaty migraine
this repulsive smg combines an obscenely
high rate of fire with incredible
stability
pretty impressive for something that
looks like it was cobbled together with
leftovers from a hog roast
it can also cause enemies to take
additional bleed damage
and turn dead enemies into bombs just
try not to think too much about how it
feels in your hands
this cool customer is called the iceberg
for obvious reasons
it's a bolt action rifle that looks like
it shouldn't work but if anything it
works almost too well with unparalleled
accuracy
superb range and a critical damage bonus
that freezes enemies in a four meter
radius
quipping stay frosty when this happens
is entirely optional
competing with the migraine in the oh
god kill it with fire stakes is the
aptly named grim marrow
constructed from bones of unknown origin
and is humidly held together by what is
scientifically known as glowy purple
stuff
it's a light machine gun designed for
crowd control its huge clip
rapid fire rate and exceptionally high
stability and accuracy
as well as the ability to slow down
enemies and trigger singularity
explosions almost make up for the fact
that it's made up from a bunch of gross
alien
bones if heavy metal was a weapon it'd
be the amber vault
which smushes together bones amber cloth
chains and what looks like someone's
scalp and somehow ends up as an
incredible double gun
if that wasn't already metal enough this
enemy mulching firearms abilities are
called killing spree
and brain eater finally we have
voodoo matchmaker a red-hot assault
rifle that is literally
always on fire it's decked out in
various charms and trinkets
and of course bones always bones
we assume these adornments are what give
it the ability to sap life from up to
three
enemies simultaneously and make them
vulnerable to increased
damage now weapons alone not even
legendary ones will guarantee survival
against the relentless hordes of
insurgents and
other altered on enoch
when selecting your class it's useful to
know what powers they will ultimately
have at their disposal
each of the four classes trickster
pyromancer devastator and technomancer
can unlock eight powers in total
four of which can be assigned at any
time understanding how these powers
combine with each other as well as your
fellow outriders powers will be critical
in building an
enemy slaughtering powerhouse tricksters
specialise in close range get in get out
combat
with powers designed to disorientate and
pick apart enemies
the sweeping temporal slice strikes
multiple enemies
paralyzing anything unfortunate enough
to be caught in its wake
it's perfect for controlling larger
groups or simply for lining up headshots
on single enemies
speaking of crowd control the slow trap
power summons a dome that slows down
both enemies and projectiles in its
radius
it's an incredibly versatile ability
that will give your entire squad time to
weave between bullets
and dodge melee attacks while they turn
everything to mincemeat
it's also the perfect way to buy time if
you need to revive
a downed teammate these two abilities
work well in tandem too
slow your enemies down to a crawl with
slow trap and add salt to the wound with
temporal slice
to give your long range favoring
accomplices some easy target
practice and when we think of long range
we think of technomancers as well as
boasting passive long-range weapon
damage buffs
these support specialists are perfect
for self and group healing
as well as introducing additional
sources of damage and status effects to
the battlefield
tool of destruction gives you the choice
of summoning a minigun or rocket
launcher which is a bit like trying to
pick between your two favorite ice cream
flavors
your choice should really reflect your
circumstances the minigun offers raw
dps advantage tearing through enoch's
hostile population with satisfying ease
but when you're up against tougher
enemies like captains and bosses
the rpg's ability to interrupt their
ruinous charged attacks is essential for
survival
we're also fans of the appropriately
named pain launcher
here the technomancer materializes an
automated missile launcher
that fires off a volley of explosive
devastation over a steadily
increasing arc and offers another means
of interrupting
big attacks if you prefer your mances a
little more hot and steamy
then the pyromancer's predilection for
burning everything to the ground
should get you fired up as you'd expect
from a flame wielding outrider the
pyromancer
is big on area of effect powers and so
is best suited to mid-range combat
their thermal bomb lets you interrupt an
unfortunate recipient
and leave them with a nasty burn
chipping away at their health over time
if said status effect ends up completely
depleting their energy
they'll become a bomb themselves and
damage any other enemies in their blast
radius
ash blast which is quite hard to say
without sounding a bit like sean connery
works well with thermal bomb
because it completely immobilizes
enemies within its radius
if one of them is also afflicted with
burn it makes it far
easier to blast away the remnants of
their health to trigger an explosion
finally there's the devastator who
despite their name
is quite the softy now just kidding
they're absolute beasts who service your
squad's tank
able to buff their hp and armor beyond
any other class
and equipped with powers designed to
keep them firmly in the heart of battle
gravity leap perfectly illustrates this
with the devastator transforming into a
collection of hovering rocks
and then reforming as they crash back
down on an enemy
not only is it likely to turn grunts
into a cloud of red
it'll also deal aoe damage to anything
else in the vicinity
gravity leap is the perfect way to
follow up after triggering endless mass
which turns an enemy into a floating
obelisk with its own gravitational pull
do not question the science it is simply
very cool
its ability to group enemies makes it
very useful for subsequent
aoe attacks and that is just a fraction
of the savage powers and legendarily
lethal weapons
that will help you unleash hell on enoch
when the creative co-op chaos of
outriders launches
april 1st
[Music]